and here's part two of my interview with
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan when I
was here in February I asked you very
specifically he gave me 200 day agenda
and then did that you said that we're
going to repeal replace he said vet
Refugees build the wall
he said not education right away and
he'd get it done in 200 days now the
house to his credit has accomplished a
lot more than the Senate I understand
that you can claim success but at Mitch
McConnell can't even appoint 2/3 of the
president's appointees and nine months
in and Mitch McConnell you have passed
200 and what 70 some-odd says that he
has not taken up yeah so the point is
we're on schedule in the house we passed
the health care bill back in May we
passed the repeal and replace at
dodd-frank we did case law we did
sanctuary cities we did the military we
did veterans we did Career and Technical
Education reforms we did school choice
for DC we did pro-life legislation we've
done all these things we passed 337
bills in the house as of this week and
you have the different administration
this is this is more than Obama in the
same time more than bush more than
Clinton more than HW Bush so more bills
have passed the House this year under
Donald Trump at this time then Obama and
both bushes in Clinton the challenge we
have is is this chart 274 of them are
still being are still in the Senate so
we haven't gotten I'm over the finish
line in the Senate now is that
frustrating for the house you bet it's
frustrating for the house you talked to
Mitch McConnell I do I do all the time
they've got they got a couple of
problems number one you mentioned it
they got up do people they have to do
personnel we don't do that now so we
don't have to confirm judges and cabinet
secretaries and assistant campus
secretaries and ambassadors all due
respect that I'm doing a lot of that
yeah Chuck Schumer can take up to 30
hours per person so he can completely go
off the works and then they have these
rules which we don't like these rules in
the house but they have these filibuster
rules the reason we're using
reconciliation for tax reform is so that
they can't filibuster
what about shouldn't they get rid of
just total simple majority in the Senate
look what you ask
House member and they'll say yes to that
is your answer yes of course I'd like to
see them do majority votes on these
studies ever ask McConnell that we've
talked about a lot I don't think that
they don't devotes therefore that's just
this flat simple answer so what do I do
to think house we don't even get the
votes to get that dog anyway doesn't
even charge of the rules is it them no
but they I don't think there's enough
Republicans to vote for that because
they worry that when liberals take over
government liberals will ran through it
but there is a there is painted though
by the Senate approval rating is you
know the way yours is double what their
approval rating in this of this Congress
is Congress is fifteen percent I think
and and if in fairness to you you will
talk to me Mitch McConnell won't even
take my call and I think the audience
that I hear from every day and they
write and they write me on social media
and they email and they they they're
voicing their frustration Congress's
approval rating fifteen percent they
want to know that this is gonna get done
yes so I actually wasn't looking for
this job as a person who wasn't looking
for leadership jobs I gotta tell you you
don't want it no no no I'm fine I'm just
saying these jobs are a lot harder on
the inside than they seem on the outside
because you have to rally support and
get get things done and get consensus
and deal with the rules and the
situations as they exist not the world
you wish you had the world you have in
front of you now in the house
we've been extraordinarily productive
we've passed our agenda we passed all of
our appropriation bills I had a
scheduled this year for the first time a
Republican majority done it since 2004
so the house usually open here in the
how you believe the house is tainted by
the inaction in the cell health care is
a perfect example
we passed a repeal and replace health
care bill in May how frustrating was at
the end was John McCain that's who
promised a hundred times to repeal
interrupt because I'm frustrated were
the ones who passed it were the ones who
said we would do this and then to see it
was by the way it wasn't easy
no it wasn't easy but it's extremely
frustrating this but here's the point
I'm trying to get at Sean yeah there are
still things we can get done even with
the rules they have over there
you know what the Congressional review
act is you can go back and rescind an
old regulation like these Obama air
regulations that was done once in twenty
years we've done 14 of them in law this
year alone because they can't filibuster
that
this tax reform bill we're gonna do it
in such a way that they can't filibuster
that and we can limit the debate on it
so we can get it done well the point is
what are you thinking with the world we
have in front of us right and that is to
get around this crazy filibuster rule
and get these things done and that is
the plan we have and I believe if
Americans see their Congress giving them
a postcard tax form giving a
middle-class tax break getting rid of
the special interest loopholes to make
it fairer and lowering taxes and
businesses to bring jobs back from
overseas and make it easier for
businesses to create more jobs here that
is going to be something that's going to
be good for all Americans
I figure paychecks more jobs I didn't
want after growth we get that done I
think people are going to be pretty
happy with with Congress and with the
president we will have kept our word
let's talk about Congress and the
president I know people that sit in the
Senate private closed-door meetings and
they write me what said I'll give you
names pence ass john mccain at least 10
or 12 senators that don't want the
president to succeed republican senators
that openly trash the president what's
your relationship with it's very good
it's very opposite we have a great
relationship are we happy with this
presidents are you very happy but you
don't have that in the House of
Representatives we have caucuses every
week you don't hear that kind of talk
from from from the House of
Representatives I have not heard it from
House members so you don't hear that
from House members look I think the
president is giving us the kind of
leadership we need to get this country
back on the right track that you think
is not conservative not that I can think
of anything that you have with it
no and you were so really comes down to
the Senate the Senate is where people
need to focus their attention look I'd
love to batch the other guys I can
control we can control but we're doing
our job here in the house and we're
rooting for friends in the Senate to get
this stuff done we're really
disappointed in health care yeah but we
still got a chance of getting a lot of
these big things too he'll be done by
December of my last question it's my
plan yes say about that all right
Paul Ryan everything is anybody answers
yes we just got to get this stuff to the
Senate and if you do by the way here's
the two
the secretary meeting caucus though
whoever group are nothing bored with
this ruins on so we're here we're on
board we're gonna get this done
but like I said we got to get this stuff
to the Senate but the great thing about
this particular issue
they can't filibuster it and that's why
I think we're gonna get this done so
last question last last question wait
when you shorten last lesson yeah so
when you show the chart that you guys
have past record number of bills and you
show that the house has passed these
laws do you feel you're treated do you
think your group didn't because of the
Senate's failure ah nothing's fair
nothing's fair in this world the
nothing's fair in politics and we're
just kind of used to that I think really
what matters to people is did we help
their lives and it really doesn't matter
whether the house yeah I mean it does
matter the House passed these bills and
we feel you know very very satisfied for
having done that but we got to get him
into law we've got to get these done so
that actually improves and affects
people lives that's how we're going to
be judged